To start solving this problem we're going to let d equal the number of dimes and
q equal the number of quarters. The question indicates the variables that we
need to use. In this case we need to know how many of each coin we have. So we
need two variables, d and q. We need to set up two equations. One will involve
the number of coins And the other would involve the value of the coins. We know
the number of dimes plus the number of quarters has to equal a total number of
coins. A register only contains dimes and quarters and it has a total number of
21 coins. So if we add the number of dimes d to the number of quarters q, we get
21. Here the variables are taking the place of the numbers. We don't know the
number of dimes so we use d, and we don't know the number of quarters so we use
q. We know the total value of the coins is $2.70. A dime is worth $0.10. So to
get the value of dimes we multiply $0.10 by the number of dimes we have. A
quarter on the other hand is worth $0.25 cents. So to get the value of the
quarters. We multiply 25 cents times our number of quarters, q. And if we add
these two values together we should get $2.70. I've rewritten the two equations
down here and now we can use either substitution or elimination to solve this
problem. I'm going to use substitution since I can easily solve for one of the
variables in this first equation. If we subtract q from both sides of this
equation, we'll get d is equal to 21 minus q. Now that d is solved for we can
perform substitution and plug in 21 minus q, and for d in our second equation.
Next I distribute 1 tenth to 21 and negative q. I combine like terms. Nest I
subtract 2 and 1 tenth from both sides. And finally I divide both sides by
fifteen hundredths. I get Q is equal to 4, which stood for the number of
quarters. So we have four quarters. But I still need to find the number of
times. My first equation I plug in 4 for Q to find the number of dimes, D.
Solving for D, I get D is equal to 17. So we have 4 quarters in a register and
17 dimes. Let's go back to our original problem and make sure that this makes
sense. We said we had 17 dimes and 4 quarters. Well, the total number of coins
should be 21 and, yes, those two add up to 21. So we know this first equation is
true. 1 dime is worth 10 cents, so 17 dimes would be worth $1.70. 1 quarter is
worth 25 cents, so 4 quarters would be worth $1. And with simple addition we
know that $1.70 and $1 add up to $2.70. So the second equation is true as well.